Brad Pitt rocks gray hair and short
shorts and only et has the pics
dark light short and long Brad Pitt has
had plenty of hairstyles over the years
but lately he's been fifty shades of
gray yeah it's for fun we're doing right
now called war machine in the upcoming
film the 52 year old plays a character
based on former US military General
Stanley McChrystal who was known for
running several miles a day the actor
got his cardio on while filming a scene
in Paris on Sunday looking almost
unrecognizable with his silver locks and
those short shorts he's practically a
running Ken doll from the front to the
back and even while he's adjusting his
shorts there's no denying the muscular
movie star looks fit in another scene
Brad swapped fitness for fatigues
wearing full camo print with his
characters named general Dan McMahon
embroidered on the jacket war machine
which also stars Topher Grace will
Poulter in Anthony Michael Hall will be
released on Netflix and in select
theaters later this year